bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat à suivre cet
après-midi l'examen en seconde lecture
de la réforme électorale annoncée par
françois hollande lors des états
généraux de la démocratie territoriale
cette réforme qui modifie le calendrier
électoral ainsi que le mode d'élection
des conseillers municipaux et
départementaux prévoit notamment un
nouveau mode de scrutin
il s'agit du scrutin binominal paritaire
qui doit entrer en vigueur lors des
prochaines élections cantonales en 2015
et selon l'article 2 du texte cette
innovation permettra d'élire un binôme
un homme et une femme
par canton c'est selon les mots mêmes de
manuel valls le ministre de l'intérieur
le gage d'une parité
enfin respectés il faut dire que
certains départements comme par exemple
le tarn et garonne ou encore les deux
sèvres ou bien la haute-corse non pas de
conseillère générale et plus
généralement selon une étude de 2002
onze les assemblées départementales ne
comporte seulement -2 14% de femmes mais
simultanément cette réforme électorale
impose un redécoupage des cantons
deux élus par circonscription
nécessitant de réduire leur nombre par
deux et c'est au ministère de
l'intérieur qui décidera seul par arrêté
de ce redécoupage le parlement n'aura
donc pas son mot à dire
résultat en janvier lors de l'examen en
première lecture de cette réforme
le sénat a voté contre l'article 2 de ce
texte par 164 voix contre 144
l'ump et les centristes ont voté contre
les communistes et les écologistes qui
réclament l'introduction de la
proportionnelle se sont abstenus en tout
cas le texte a été vidé de sa substance
par le sénat
mais depuis l'assemblée l'a réintroduit
le 27 février tout de suite donc
direction l'hémicycle pour cette réforme
électorale très bonne après midi à tous
sur notre chaîne l'ordre du jour appelle
la discussion du projet de loi modifié
par l'assemblée nationale relatif à
l'élection des conseillers
départementaux des conseillers
municipaux et des délégués
comme communautaire et modifiant le
calendrier électoral et du projet de loi
organique modifié par l'assemblée
nationale relatif à l'élection des
conseillers municipaux délégués
communautaires et des conseillers
départementaux
la conférence des présidents a décidé
que ces deux textes ferait l'objet d'une
discussion générale commune dans la
discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur manuel valls
ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le président monsieur le
président de la commission des lois le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs il y a deux mois de cela
j'étais ici devant vous il neigeait déjà
afin de marquer le début d'une étape
importante pour nos institutions celle
de l'approfondissement et de la
modernisation de la démocratie dans nos
territoires et je vous retrouve
évidemment avec beaucoup de plaisir
il s'agit là d'une étape qui nous
appartient de franchir dans un esprit de
dialogue et autant que faire se peut
dans un esprit de consensus
aujourd'hui je soumets de nouveau à
votre examen
ces deux projets de loi aujourd'hui une
question se pose à tous les groupes et
je dis bien à tous les groupes
ce nouvel examen permettra t-il au sénat
de participer à la définition de
nouvelles règles pour les élections
locales en première lecture nous avons
eu de longs échanges mais ce fut
finalement un rendez vous manqué or on
ne saurait manquer me semble-t-il un
rendez vous avec la démocratie et avec
la démocratie locale en particulier
notre responsabilité et je prends ma
place
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs est
donc grande et ne feignons pas en en
effet d'ignorer le doute qui s'est
emparée de nos concitoyens et ce qui
vaut pour la france vaut d'ailleurs pour
l'europe il y à une crise du système
représentatif qui appelle les électeurs
à ne plus croire dans la capacité de
leurs représentants entendre leurs
attentes à répondre à leurs
préoccupations
je veux le dire ici avec gravité nous
avons le devoir impérieux et plus encore
dans les temps actuels marqué par les
difficultés de renforcer nos
institutions de restaurer pleinement
cette confiance qui est essentiel au bon
fonctionnement de notre démocratie qui
est essentiel aussi
pour la prémunir contre les poussées
populistes qui toujours se sont
alimentés de ses faiblesses être élu du
peuple est une belle mission c'est une
mission qui a aussi sa part d'exigences
être élu du peuple et vous tous ici en
est le témoignage
c'est assumer une part de ce qu'est
notre présent mais également de ce que
sera notre avenir
les élus chacun dans leurs différentes
responsabilités sont l'expression d'une
volonté générale
ils sont la vitalité de notre démocratie
pour autant et vous le savez des voix
parfois s'élèvent pour les mettre en
cause pour dire aussi qu'ils sont trop
nombreux
qu'il coûte cher ces critiques
comment peut-on ne pas vouloir y
répondre et la meilleure des manières et
toujours de consolider ce lien précieux
qui unit les citoyens à leurs
représentants et c'est précisément
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs cela
que vise ce texte de loi
je le disais lien instant notre premier
rendez-vous a été manquée
je vous propose donc d'essayer de
réussir ce nouveau rendez vous c'est en
tout cas dans cet état d'esprit que
j'aborde cette discussion sur la base du
texte adopté en commission des lois et
toutes les modifications encore il ya
quelques heures qui ont été apportées le
débat d'aujourd'hui s'inscrivent à la
suite d'un processus
et il m'apparaît utile d'en rappeler les
grandes étapes
c'est ici au sénat il ya plus d'un an
qu'a été adopté une proposition de loi
abrogeant le conseiller territorial
c'est encore ici au sénat en octobre
dernier à votre initiative monsieur le
président ont été organisés les états
généraux de la démocratie territoriale
et à l'issue d'une consultation large et
de débats approfondis
le président de la république a fixés
les quatre grands principes qui doivent
guider la prochaine étape de la
décentralisation confiance clarté
cohérence et démocratie cette démocratie
elle vit dans le territoire dans les
régions les départements les communes au
rythme des lois de décentralisation et
les transferts de compétences depuis 30
ans c'est une véritable culture de la
démocratie locale qui s'est
progressivement affirmé
elle est faite de dialogue de
concertation de proximité elle s'appuie
sur des élus locaux vous êtes aussi les
élus locaux qui ont à coeur de servir
leurs collectivités de mettre en
mouvement les territoires dont ils ont
la charge
cette culture de la démocratie locale
nos concitoyens ils sont
particulièrement attachés ils savent en
effet combien elle les a rapprochés de
la décision publique
combien elle leur a permis de mieux
faire entendre leur voix
la démocratie locale a été une conquête
majeure dans notre république et dans
cette conquête démocratique le
département a occupé une place
importante
une place historique qui renvoie aux
acquis même de la révolution et de la
troisième république
ce constat lui seul pose le degré
d'exigence que nous devons avoir pour la
démocratie locale dans nos départements
qui incarne mieux que tous les autres
la diversité de nos territoires urbains
périurbains et ruraux la montagne le
littoral les îles la métropole et
outre-mer afin de prolonger fidèlement
cet héritage c'est en ce sens que la
réforme de 2010 je ne vise pas mesdames
et messieurs l'opposition à vous
convaincre instaurant le conseiller
territorial confondait deux échelons le
département et la région qui n'ont pas
les mêmes logiques de fonctionnement ni
les mêmes perspectives d'action elle
introduisait donc par ce biais une
confusion en matière de compétences
or la démocratie locale a besoin de
transparence
c'est là sa force c'est ce qui fait
toute sa pertinence
la démocratie locale c'est accroître
l'information du citoyen
c'est mieux l'associer au processus de
décision c'est concevoir la démocratie
comme un lien permanent entre les
électeurs et leurs élus et non pas comme
des rencontres ponctuelles au rythme des
scrutins c'est faire de l' échange
régulier entre les citoyens un élément
de la vitalité démocratique je ne vous
apprends rien et le conseiller
territorial éloignait l'élu de son
territoire
il mettait de la distance entre l'élu et
les citoyens c'est à dire entre l'élu et
la société dont il est censé porter les
aspirations
le mode de scrutin était par ailleurs
très défavorable à la parité et
représentait de ce point de vue là une
régression par rapport au scrutin
régional
l'abrogation du conseiller territorial
et est donc une nécessité
cependant rien ne sert d'abroger sans
proposer et en matière de démocratie on
ne peut se contenter d'un simple retour
en arrière est la seule voie possible
c'est l'approfondissement
qui peut penser en effet que dans la
france d'aujourd'hui on puisse élire des
conseillers généraux sur la base d'une
carte qui pour les deux tiers remonte à
comment refuser de voir que la
répartition démographique en deux
siècles a profondément évolué
cet aspect est fondamental car il
renvoie un principe démocratique
un principe constitutionnel d'égalité
devant le suffrage et quelle égalité
lorsque le rapport entre le canton le
moins peuplé et le plus peuplé d'un même
département peut atteindre 1 pour 47
quelle égalité également qu'en 18
départements dans 18 départements
ce rapport est supérieur à 1 pour 20
et quand dans 88 départements soit la
presque totalité
il dépasse 1 pour 5 nous ne pouvons plus
accepter de telles inégalités qui font
que les choix de certains citoyens pèse
moins que celle d'autres citoyens
un redécoupage globale de la carte
cantonale s'impose donc
remodelée n'est jamais chose aisée
parait-il est le seul recours utile
c'est celui de grands principes
ap
key uniformément aussi avons-nous fait
le choix d'une règle simple les cas
entre la population d'un canton données
et la moyenne départementale ne pourra
excéder 20%
ce chiffre ne relève pas du hasard il
celui que le conseil constitutionnel
retient pour le redécoupage des
circonscriptions législatives
c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi le conseil
d'état l'a préconisé dans la vie qu'il
m'a rendu parallèlement à l'élaboration
de ce projet loi nous avons discuté de
ce sujet en première lecture je ne doute
pas que nous allons encore en rediscuter
si évidemment le scrutin binominal est
acceptée par le sénat cette discussion
sur ce sujet là aura lieu mais pas l'
inverse
vous le comprendrez bien qui peut non
c'est la cohérence
qui peut penser également que dans la
france d'aujourd'hui on puisse encore
concevoir un mode de scrutin
départemental qui ne serait pas
paritaire
la parité a progressé partout dans les
municipalités dans les régions au
gouvernement au parlement également même
s'il reste des progrès à faire
et dans ce mouvement d'ensemble les
départements font figure d'exception et
une exception
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs qui
ne pouvait plus durer
c'est pourquoi dans chaque canton seront
élus solidairement deux candidats de
sexe différent la parité sera donc
assurée c'est là une exigence
démocratique qui transformera
profondément les assemblées
départementales qui fera en sorte
qu'elle soit à l'image de la société
la parité les assemblées ne se traduit
pas nécessairement de leur exécutif je
ne vous apprends rien non plus 95% des
présidents et 95 et 85% des
vice-présidents des actuels conseillers
généraux sont des hommes et ce texte
propose donc d'étendre l'obligation de
parité
comme c'est le cas pour les régions à
l'exécutif départemental
qui peut penser que dans la france
d'aujourd'hui qui a enfin réussi la
révolution de l'intercommunalité
les responsables de ces structures aux
compétences et aux responsabilités
croissantes ne soit pas élu directement
par les électeurs
pour nombre de nos concitoyens l'échelon
intercommunal est une réalité dont ils
ont pleinement conscience
ils savent très bien pour le vivre
quotidiennement que c'est à ce niveau
que se prennent les décisions dans de
nombreux domaines la voirie les
infrastructures les transports la
culture et demain plus encore
notamment en matière de développement
économique ou de formation cette réalité
les politiques publiques de devenu une
réalité démocratique
c'est l'objectif du système de fléchage
proposées par ce projet de loi il
s'agira d'identifier sur la même liste
que celle de l'élection municipale
ceux et celles qui seront appelés à
siéger au conseil de l'intercommunalité
ce système permet de préserver l'échelon
municipal n'exigeant ce que je partage
et notamment la figure du maire à
laquelle les français sont légitimement
attachés c'est l'échelon de proximité
par excellence tout en donnant c'est le
but du texte une plus grande lisibilité
aux électeurs qui peut penser enfin que
dans la france d'aujourd'hui on laisse
encore s'appliquer dans bien des
communes le jeu parfois étonnants du
ratures âge et du panachage
pour éviter cela ce projet de loi
propose d'abaisser le seuil à partir
duquel les élections municipales sont
organisées au scrutin de liste
proportionnel le gouvernement avait
proposé le seuil de 1000 habitants
le sénat l'avait approuvée l'assemblée
nationale a retenu celui de 500
habitants qui ferait que 93 % de la
population voterait avec ce mode de
scrutin pour les élections municipales
un mode de scrutin qui par ailleurs
garantit la parité égalité devant le
suffrage parité démocratisation de
l'intercommunalité
tels sont les objectifs auxquels entend
répondre ce projet de loi nous pouvons
encore débattre des solutions
préconisées dans ces domaines par les
uns
et par les autres mais en aucun cas nous
ne devons dévier des grandes
orientations fixées par le président de
la république et nous avons là mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs l'opportunité
de donner une impulsion nouvelle que je
crois forte et cohérente et au moment de
reprendre nos débats je veux vous dire
en toute franchise dans quel état
d'esprit se trouve le gouvernement
nous avons une ambition pour le
démocratie locale
mais nous savons aussi très bien qu'une
réforme est d'autant plus efficace
qu'elle se fait dans un climat de
sérénité et qu'elle s'appuie sur une
assise la plus large possible
comme tout texte celui ci mérite sans
doute d'être enrichi encore sur de
nombreux points
corrigé peut-être sur d'autres c'est
tout le sens du travail parlementaire
le gouvernement est donc prêt un certain
nombre de débats de compromis mais pas à
se compromettre et j'ai dressé un
constat esquissé des pistes
j'en tire des conclusions précises mais
aussi des exigences que je rappellerai
tout au long de nos futures discussions
l'assemblée nationale a fourni comme le
sénat l'assemblée nationale a approuvé
le texte
un travail important sur de nombreux
points elle l'a enrichi elle a introduit
aussi des avancées notables
je pense par exemple aux critères qui
doivent présider au futur redécoupage et
garantir une bonne représentation de la
diversité de le territoire était au
coeur d'un certain nombre de nos
discussions en première lecture ce texte
celui qui a été transmis à votre
assemblée est donc satisfaisant pour le
gouvernement
les travaux de votre commission des lois
ont permis d'aboutir
jusqu'à il ya quelques minutes à
l'adoption d'un texte celui que nous
examinons aujourd'hui à bien des égards
il s'éloigne des travaux de l'assemblée
nationale mais je veux vous redire ma
volonté de mener un dialogue constructif
avec l'ensemble des groupes du sénat je
l'avais dit déjà devant vous afin de
déboucher sur un texte
et là je veux le souligner tout
particulièrement qui vous engage et qui
permettent
au sénat qui permettent à votre
assemblée qui vous permette vous qui
représentez les collectivités locales
d'apporter votre contribution à cette
réforme dans la construction de cet
accord certains points sont fondamentaux
pour gouvernement tout d'abord le mode
de scrutin binominal c'est la substance
de la réforme que je vous propose
d'accomplir
c'est aussi le seul moyen car je n'ai
pas entendu d'autres de concilier les
deux exigences de parité et d'ancrage
territorial et je le dis non la
proportionnelle la proportionnelle ne
permet pas l'ancrage territorial et le
retour en arrière ne permet pas la
parité
maintenant nous sommes en deuxième
lecture chacun connaît les arguments
donc si on veut et la parité et
l'ancrage territorial il faut voter et
je le dis à la majorité comme à
l'opposition pour le scrutin binominal
l'élection madame la présidente le
pluralisme
c'est le choix des électeurs le scrutin
majoritaire à deux tours
n'empêche pas le pluralisme ni à
l'assemblée ni au sénat donc et la
parité et la parité elle est possible
pour ce qui concerne et la parité je ne
fais aucune leçon je me le permettrais
pas madame la présidente je veux
uniquement vous dire que la parité vous
en prie madame la présidente
j'ai déjà dit que je voulais entamé ce
débat dans le meilleur état d'esprit
mais je vous écoute avec la plus grande
attention
mais le gouvernement n'acceptera pas la
proportionnelle pour ce qui concerne les
départements et nous voulons en même
temps la parité voilà si on veut ce lien
et je vous rappelle que y compris votre
organisation politique à nîmes deux
départements à anime deux départements
et c'est ici au scrutin départemental
donc ça n'est pas antinomique avec une
représentation
pas de faux débats entre nous avec une
représentation des forces politiques
mais le département tel que nous le
concevons telles que je les décris comme
il est représentatif de le territoire et
de leur diversité nécessite des élus
qu'ils soient ancrés dans cette réalité
et en même temps nous voulons cette
parité
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
l'élection par fléchage des délégués
communautaires est également un point
essentiel
je suis très sensible aux propositions
concernant marseille et lyon puisqu'il
va y avoir des amendements dans ce sens
c'est là aussi on posant les bases d'une
démocratie intercommunale abouti que
nous pourrons envisager l'avenir de ces
territoires
enfin la modification du calendrier
électoral est un troisième élément
fondamental
il s'agit de garantir une meilleure
participation aux élections locales et
par la concomitance des élections
régionales et départementales de créer
en tout cas nous l'espérons des
dynamiques communes à des échelons
territoriaux sur ces quelques points
le gouvernement restera vigilant à ce
que le texte ne soit pas dénaturé nous
prenons également garde à ce que ce
texte reste compatit
le avec la jurisprudence
constitutionnelle
il y va de la pérennité de cette réforme
il y va de notre crédibilité à tous
j'ai donc déposé un certain nombre
d'amendements au texte de votre
commission
au nom du gouvernement mais comme vous
le constatez le champ des débats restent
très large et je suis très sensible à
toutes les propositions constructives
qui permettront de garantir par exemple
une bonne représentation de nos
territoires euros tout le débat que nous
avons eu
n'en doutez pas un seul instant tous les
tous les débats que nous avons eus au
sénat en première lecture
comme à l'assemblée nationale tous les
discussions que nous avons eues tous les
échanges qui se sont fait jour nous ont
permis me semble-t-il d'avancer sur ce
sujet là parce que nous sommes bien
conscients que la taille des cantons la
représentation d'un certain nombre de
territoires nécessite à la fois des
critères le sénat y avait travaillé
l'assemblée où tout est si évidemment
chacun s'engage pour ce qui concerne le
scrutin binominal je crois que nous
pouvons intelligemment avancer sans nous
mettre en difficulté par rapport à la
jurisprudence constitutionnelle
vous connaissez ainsi mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs les données de
notre débat et je vous invite donc très
poliment à vous inscrire dans cette
perspective de dialogue mais pour que
cet exercice de franchie soit fructueux
chacun doit s'y livrer chacun doit dire
clairement ce qu'il veut
doit préciser quel est son projet pour
les collectivités
chacun doit également en toute
transparence expliquer les évolutions
possibles
il ne servirait à rien qu'une seule
partie fasse des compromis
un accord cela se construit ensemble et
vous savez et vous l'avez compris le
gouvernement y est prêt
merci le ministre
la parole est à présent monsieur michel
delebarre rapporteur de la commission
des lois
le plus fort est en jeu
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois
mesdames messieurs aujourd'hui notre
assemblée de nouveau saisi de deux
projets de loi relatif à l'élection des
conseillers départementaux
les conseillers communautaires et
modifiant le calendrier électoral
ce projet de loi qui je le rappelle a
été rejetée le 18 janvier dernier tandis
que le projet de loi organique a été lui
adopté à l'unanimité le scrutin
binominal départementale n'est pas
parvenu à réunir une majorité d'adhésion
c'était hier
c'est un moment d'histoire nous sommes
là pour en construire un autre moment de
l'histoire le 26 février dernier
l'assemblée nationale a voté ces deux
projets de loi en en conservant
larchitecture général en les
enrichissant de nombreuses dispositions
nouvelles je rappellerai rapidement
d'abord les travaux du sénat en première
lecture le 19 décembre dernier notre
commission a adopté un certain nombre
d'améliorations rédactionnelles ainsi
que quelques novation comme celle
majeurs proposés par notre collègue
pierre yves collombat qui renverse le
principe traditionnel d'acquisition de
l'élection en cas d'égalité des
suffrages
désormais celle-ci serait acquise plus
jeunes en séance publique
le sénat a supprimé l'article 2 relatif
au mode de scrutin binominal ce qui a
conduit par cohérence à rejeter des
articles 106 8 9 10 11 12 et 13 qui
proposait les coordination nécessaire
dans le code électoral à ce mode de
scrutin
toutefois avant le rejet global du
présent projet de loi notre assemblée a
adopté le changement d'appellation du
conseil général l'abrogation du
conseiller territorial article 1er 25 le
renouvellement intégral des conseils
départementaux tous les six ans article
4 ainsi que la procédure applicable
lorsque nombre de conseillers
département
oh non domiciliés dans le département
est supérieur au quart de l'effectif du
conseil départemental
article 7 s'agissant du remodelage de la
carte cantonale
le cdh a également supprimé les articles
3 et 23 en raison des inquiétudes
exprimées sur la représentation des
territoires faiblement peu près peuplé
et leur prise en compte dans les
politiques départementales c'est
pourquoi j'avais déposé un amendement
adopté à l'unanimité par le sénat qui
proposait d'élargir les dérogations
principe de remodelage de la carte
cantonale aux dérogations géographiques
étaient ajoutés les dérogations
démographique déquilibre d'aménagement
du territoire ainsi que le nombre de
communes
ces dérogations étaient est fixée par un
décret en conseil d'état le sénat
complétaient le dispositif proposé pour
réformer le régime électoral municipal
afin d'en préserver la cohérence et de
faciliter la vie municipale tout d'abord
il s'en est tenu aux seuils
d'application d'un proportionnelle 2000
habitants raisonnable au regard des
conséquences induites par
l'élargissement de la proportionnelle
pour les communes concernées et de
l'objectif de parité et modalités de
candidature et de vote dans les communes
de moins de 2000 habitants ont été
complétés sur deux points d'une part
pour préciser les modalités de publicité
des candidatures que la commission des
lois avait rendu obligatoire et d'autre
part pour interdire à un candidat le
dette dans plus d'une circonscription
électorale
en conséquence du principe de
l'obligation de candidature alors que
les bulletins de vote incomplet et le
panachage ont été maintenus dans les
communes de moins de 1000 habitants
le nom de non candidats les noms des non
candidats qui seraient portées ne serait
pas décompté lors du dépouillement du
scrutin
à l'initiative de votre commission des
lois senna a complété le projet de loi
organique pour aligner le mandat
municipal pris en compte au titre de la
limitation du cumul des mandats sur le
seuil de 1000 habitants par référence
aux critères objectifs du seuil du
changement de mode de scrutin
enfin pour répondre aux difficultés de
candidature la commission des lois a
diminué de 2 unités l'effectif des
conseils municipaux dans les communes de
moins de 500 habitants
cette opération a été poursuivi dans les
dés
en séance publique pour un certain
nombre d'autres catégories de communes
c'est un point sur lequel nous serons
amenés à revenir
s'agissant du fléchage le sénat
souhaitait offrir aux collectivités le
moyen de mieux coordonner
responsabilités communales et
intercommunales en assouplissant le
dispositif gouvernemental du stockage en
tête de liste des candidats fléchés pour
le conseil de l'intercommunalité
l'objectif est de concilier d'une part
la liberté du choix des candidatures
fléché selon des modalités clairement
déterminées d'autre part la sincérité du
scrutin
c'est pourquoi dans les communes de 1000
habitants et plus notre haute assemblée
a limité la faculté de flécher à une
partie de la liste seulement
s'administre nous n'aurons pas fini de
débattre y compris du fléchage la
vacance de siège pour quelque cause que
ce soit seraient pourvus par le suivant
de liste afin de conforter la légitimité
démocratique des conseils communautaires
du sera élu demain au suffrage universel
direct
les candidats qui figureront sur la
liste des candidats au conseil municipal
figurent aussi séparément leur bulletin
de vote dans l'ordre de leur
présentation
enfin le sénat régler le cas de la
section électorale qui par le jeu de la
répartition des sièges attribués à la
commune entre les sections ou secteurs
municipaux à la proportionnelle de leur
population ne se verra attribuer aucun
délégué au sein de l'intercommunalité
afin de permettre la participation des
électeurs au choix des délégués
communautaires
l'élection du ou des délégués ceinture
et alors où l'ensemble de la commune
comme s'il n'y avait pas de
sectionnement je conclurai ce bref
rappel de nos travaux de première
lecture en mentionnant l'adoption d'une
nouvelle dérogation critères
démographiques de création d'une
communauté d'agglomération
l'assemblée nationale a retenu
architecture générale de la réforme de
scrutins locaux laquelle a été prolongé
par diverses mesures qui ne sont pas
toutes de nature électorale elle a
adopté l'ensemble des dispositions
relatives au nouveau mode de scrutin les
conseillers départementaux ainsi que
l'abrogation du conseiller territorial
elle apportait plusieurs ennemis
plusieurs améliorations rédactionnelle
dont plusieurs avaient été proposée et
adoptée par notre commission des lois
par le sénat parmi celles ci citons
l'article 1er bis qui réaffirme le rôle
du département comme garant de la
solidarité sociale et de la solidarité
territoriale
l'article 5 bis allonge le délai
interdit sans à certains responsables de
services départementaux de se présenter
aux élections départementales sinon pas
au préalable abandonner leurs fonctions
au sein de ce département
au moins un an auparavant de même en
vertu des articles 6 bis tout conseiller
départemental qui se seraient présentés
ou serait élue dans un autre canton lors
d'une élection partielle serait déclaré
démissionnaire d'office par le préfet de
département de son monde en cours ce qui
permettrait de conserver le nouveau
mandat
l'article cette ville dispose en
revanche que tout candidat qui se
présenteraient simultanément dans
plusieurs cantons
en dépit de l'interdiction posée par
l'article lui qui dispose que nul ne
peut être candidat donc plus d'un quand
on perdrait de plein droit ses mandats
de conseiller départemental le candidat
ainsi élu serait déclaré démissionnaire
d'office de l'ensemble de ses mandats
par le préfet de département
l'article lui étant désormais à
l'ensemble des cantons la déclaration
pour les binômes de candidats d'un
mandataire financier aujourd'hui
réservées dans les seuls cantons depuis
de 9000 habitants sur la question du
remodelage de la carte cantonale
l'assemblée nationale a adopté tout
temps les précisant les dispositions
relatives au remodelage de cette carte
ainsi elle a repris là maintenant que le
gouvernement avait déposé en séance
publique au sénat à l'article 3 selon
lequel d'une part le nombre de cantons
dans lesquels seraient élus le futur
conseillers départementaux serait égal à
la moitié du nombre de cantons existant
au 1er janvier 2013 à randy à l'unité
supérieure
un père et d'autre part le nombre de
cantons dans les départements de plus de
cinq cent mille habitants ne pourrait
être inférieure à 15 le nombre des
conseillers départementaux à mayotte a
été relevé à 26 pour tenir compte de
cette règle de calcul du nombre de
cantons un père la combinaison de ces
deux articles permet le maintien de 52
cantons supplémentaires par rapport aux
dispositions initiales du projet de loi
s'agissant des principes encadrant la
procédure de remodelage de la carte
cantonale
l'assemblée nationale a repris dans son
esprit l'amendement que j'avais déposé
au nom de notre commission et qui avait
été adoptée à l'unanimité par le sénat
ainsi les dérogations concernerait outre
des considérations géographiques et
toutes autres motifs d'intérêt général
les considérations démographiques et
d'aménagement du territoire
ces dérogations été complétée afin de
préciser les dérogations géographique
pour tenir compte de la superficie du
relief de la su l'arrêter et de prendre
en compte le nombre de communes pour
éviter la constitution de canton par
trop étendue l'assemblée nationale a
complété le dispositif concept fois au
régime électoral municipal
certaines de ses dispositions nouvelles
ont été initiées par le sénat article 16
l'assemblée nationale a et en lui
souhaitant proportionnelle aux communes
de 500 habitants
son rapporteur le député pascal popelin
a toutefois rappelé que les avis étaient
très partagés sur le niveau
démographique à retenir mais qu'un
consensus se dégage en tout état de
cause pour la baisser ensuite
s'inscrivant dans la voie ouverte par le
sénat l'assemblée nationale généralisée
l'obligation de déclarer le déclarer sa
candidature à toutes les communes quel
que soit le mode de scrutin applicable
alors en conséquence modifié le régime
encadrant l'élection municipale dans les
communes relevant du scrutin majoritaire
et adapter la situation d'une personne
et lui le même jour dans plusieurs
communes laquelle serait déchue de plein
droit de l'ensemble de ses mandats
municipaux
elle a précisé les mesures de publicité
des candidatures l'article 25 bis
réintègre le contentieux municipal dans
le droit commun à l'instar de la petite
10 pour les élections départementales en
supprimant l'exception spécifique au
principe de l'effet suspensif d'appel au
conseil d'état enfin l'article 18 bis
diminue de 2 unités
l'effectif des conseils municipaux des
communes de moins de 3500 habitants en
conservant parallèlement le même nombre
d'électeurs sénatoriaux que celui
aujourd'hui en vigueur
les députés ont donc largement poursuivi
la voie ouverte par le sénat l'assemblée
nationale a ajusté le volet
intercommunal a tout d'abord qualifié
les membres des organes délibérants des
epci à fiscalité propre de conseillers
intercommunale appellation qui lui
paraît plus conforme à leur nouveau
régime de désignation suffrage universel
l'assemblée nationale a également
organisé les conséquences
une suppression d'une dissolution de
l'annulation de l'élection d'un conseil
municipal sur la composition et le
fonctionnement de l'organe délibérant de
le p6 à fiscalité propre auquel
appartient la commune concernée en
prorogeant le mandat de ses délégués
jusqu'à l'élection suivante
l'inégibilité d'un ou de plusieurs
candidats dans le cadre du scrutin
proportionnel municipal n'entraînerait
l'annulation de l'élection que du ou des
élus inéligible alors remplacé par le
suivant de liste n'exerçant pas de
mandat intercommunale les modalités
d'attribution des sièges ou sections
électorales nomades mille habitants qui
correspond à une commune associée loi
marcellin à une communes déléguées loi
de 2010 ont été remaniées au profit du
maire délégué puis des conseils
municipaux de la section dans l'ordre
décroissant du nombre de suffrages
obtenus par ailleurs au cas où par le
jeu de la proportionnelle une section
n'obtiendrait aucun siège les sections
électorales de la commune seraient
supprimés cependant dans les communes de
plus de 500 habitants le territoire de
chacune d'entre elles seraient alors
institué en communes déléguées soumises
au régime rénover des communes nouvelles
par la loi du 16 décembre 2010 je ne
peux pas dire que le sénat va suivre a
semblé gêner l'assemblée nationale sur
chacun de ces points
le tableau de la municipalité
aujourd'hui de nature réglementaire est
légalisée en raison de son intervention
dans l'attribution des sièges de
conseillers communautaires les
inéligibilité frappant le mandat
municipal ont été complétés aurait
intégré les emplois de direction au sein
du service de nos pays à fiscalité
propre carrière par ailleurs le régime
d'incompatibilité entoura le mandat de
conseiller intercommunale a été étendue
à l'exercice d'un emploi salarié au sein
de le pc ou de ses communes membres
enfin
le nouvelle retouche sur règles de
composition des conseils communautaires
ont été apportées l'article 25 yes he
poos de deux mois la date limite fixée
aux communes membres d'une communauté de
communes ou les communautés
d'agglomération pour parvenir à un
accord sur la répartition des sièges au
sein du conseil de l'intercommunalité
le mandat des délégués des pays à
fiscalité propre qui fusionne en 1er
janvier 2014 est prorogé jusqu'à
l'installation de l'organe délibérant de
l'intercommunalité issue de la fusion
dans sa composition résultant des
élections de mars 2014
cependant durant la période transitoire
un exécutif collégial composé des
présidents les établissements fusionnés
gérer les affaires courantes et urgentes
l'article 20 pièces propose d'élire au
suffrage universel direct
les membres du comité d'un syndicat
d'agglomération nouvelle et de lui
tendre les règles entourant la
composition des organes délibérants des
epci à fiscalité propre
l'assemblée nationale enfin d'octets
plusieurs mesures ponctuelles qui ne
sont pas toutes de nature électorale
l'article 19 bis opère dans le régime du
cumul des députés européens
une coordination analogue à celle
effectuée pour les parlementaires
nationaux par l'article 1er du projet de
loi organique
il aligne banque le mandat municipal
visé par l'incompatibilité sur nouveaux
seuils d'application du scrutin
municipal proportionnelle prolonge en
initiatives sénatoriales l'article 24 du
filtre régime de l'écrêtement
indemnitaire en prévoyant le renverse le
reversement de l'écrêtement obligé la
personne publique au sein de laquelle
l'élu concerné exerce plus récemment un
mandat ou une fonction
ce dispositif a été étendu aux membres
des conseils territoriaux de
saint-barthélemy de saint-martin et de
saint-pierre-et-miquelon par l'article 2
ter du projet de loi organique
l'article 21 à règle le sort des
indemnités attaché au mandat de l'élu en
situation d'incompatibilité
pendant la période du droit d'option qui
lui est ouvert pour régulariser sa
situation tant que celle ci ne sera pas
réglé l'élu ne percevrait aucune
indemnité attaché au dernier mandat
acquis ou renouveler l'article 21 b
réaffirme le droit en interdisant le
versement des indemnités perçues par les
élus
aux partis politiques ou aux candidats
par le biais de leur collectivité
l'article 27 pièces prévoit une double
dérogation critères démographiques de
création d'une communauté
d'agglomération ma titre expérimental
pour une durée de trois ans à compter de
la promulgation du présent projet de loi
tout en approuvant différentes novation
voté par les députés
la commission des lois a maintenu sa
position de première lecture sur les
principaux fondements du texte tout en
adoptant des modifications
substantielles
elle a aussi supprimé certains ajouts de
l'assemblée nationale soit parce qu'il
soulève des difficultés soit parce
qu'ils excèdent l'objet du présent tête
sur le volley départemental
la commission des lois adoptées outre
des amendements rédactionnels plusieurs
modifications certaines d'entre elles
ayant déjà été voté en première lecture
ainsi à l'article 5 la commission
rétablie le principe selon lequel en cas
d'égalité du suffrage entre deux binômes
l'élection est acquise à celui
comportant le candidat le plus jeune le
même critère a été retenue pour
l'attribution de sièges en cas d'égalité
du suffrage au scrutin majoritaire
elle a abrogé l'article 7 l'article 209
du code électoral relatif à la
domiciliation des conseillers
départementaux et à ses conséquences
lorsque les conseillers non domiciliées
dans un département représente plus du
quart des membres du conseil elle a
également adopté le principe selon
lequel seuls deux binômes deux candidats
arrivés en tête au premier tour peuvent
se maintenir au second tour lors des
élections départementales mais là dessus
aussi
les choses ont évolué de même à
l'article 9
la commission a prévu l'organisation
d'une élection partielle en cas de
vacance d'un siège de conseiller
départemental dans un contour s'agissant
de l'arctique 23 la commission a
introduit plusieurs modifications
elle a élargi le second critère
résistant le remodelage de la carte
cantonale toute commune dans la
population serait inférieure au dixième
de la population moyenne des cantons du
département ne pourrait être réparti
entre plusieurs cantons elle a également
relevé l'écart entre la population d'un
canton et la population moyenne des
cantons du même département de 20% à 30%
enfin elle à préciser les dérogations
principes régissant
le redécoupage de la carte cantonale qui
seraient définies par un décret en
conseil d'état sur le volet communal la
commission des lois a rétabli le seuil
de 1000 habitants
pour l'application du scrutin municipal
proportionnelle qui lui paraît léchage
de mieux ajuster regarde la diversité et
des spécificités communal sur le volet
intercommunal la commission a tout
d'abord choisi de qualifier les membres
des organes délibérants des ep sears
qu'elle des profs de conseillers
communautaires
cet appel à 100 il paraît mieux refléter
les coopératives de projets qui
constituent selon l'expression
pertinente du père de la loi du 12
juillet 1999
notre collègue jean pierre chevènement
puis elle a supprimé le lien de
dépendance du mandat municipal
d'arrondissement au sort du mandat
intercommunale établi par les députés la
commission des loi rétablit un
assouplissement des modalités du
fléchage sur les listes des candidats au
conseil communautaire dans les communes
de 1000 habitants et plus elle a repris
en matière de sectionnement électoral
le mécanisme de votée par le sénat en
première lecture
lorsqu'une section électorale ne se
verrait pas attributs ne se verra
attribuer aucun siège à
l'intercommunalité l'élection des
conseillers communautaires où il aurait
alors lieu sur l'ensemble du périmètre
communal comme s'il n'y avait pas de
sections afin de respecter le principe
de l'égalité des suffrages la commission
a simplifié dans les communes régie par
le scrutin majoritaire
le régime des vacances au conseil de
l'intercommunalité qui seraient pourvus
dans l'ordre du tableau de la
municipalité quel que soit son motif
elle a confié à l'exécutif de le pc asus
qualités propres résultant d'une fusion
d'établissements 1er janvier 2014
durant la période transitoire s'étendant
jusqu'à l'élection de son organe
délibérant au mois de mars suivant aux
paysages et des présidents des opci et
en fusionner comme le prévoit déjà le
code général des collectivités
territoriales pour le droit commun de
fusion elle a maintenu le dispositif en
vigueur pour régler la composition de
l'organe délibérant des opci à fiscalité
propre
entre deux renouvellements généraux des
conseils municipaux en cas de fusion ou
d'extension de leur périple
elle a écarté l'extension du régime de
composition de désignation d un pays à
fiscalité propre syndicat
d'agglomération nouvelle qui constitue
une structure de gestion d'une opération
d'urbanisme et est appelée à disparaître
l'achèvement des travaux d'aménagement
elle a supprimé la dérogation
expérimental aux critères démographiques
de création d'une communauté
d'agglomération considérer cette
disposition
excédé l'objet du présent texte ainsi
que l'application des dispositions du
projet de loi en nouvelle calédonie en
polynésie française soit parce que la
législation relative à
l'intercommunalité ne s'applique pas
soit parce qu'elles prévoient des
spécificités enfin commission a fixé
l'entrée en vigueur de la réforme de
l'écrêtement indemnitaire à la date du
renouvellement de la peau et 8 est
concernée afin d'en faciliter la mise en
oeuvre la réforme à nouveau soumise à
notre examen renforcera la légitimité
des élus à travers l'innovation proposée
non je ne mésestime pas l'ampleur en
adaptant la loi aux évolutions de la
gestion locale elle permettra aussi une
plus grande diversité de la composition
des assemblées délibérantes en
conséquence la commission des loi soumet
à la délibération du sénat le texte
elle a établi pour le projet de loi
organique et le projet de loi avec le
président jean pierre sueur et la
plupart des membres de la commission des
lois nous souhaitons monsieur le
ministre
apporter notre pierre à l'édification de
la loi qui nous concerne aujourd'hui
sans rien ignorer de nos convictions
profondes sans les sous-estimer nous
avons souhaité travailler avec une
volonté constructive certaine il
convient aujourd'hui de franchir une
dernière étape qui peut être essentielle
pour le sénat dans son rôle de
représentant des collectivités
territoriales je vous remercie de votre
attention
merci monsieur le rapporteur dans la
suite de la discussion générale commune
de la parole est à monsieur jean jacques
hyest pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le 26
février dernier une très courte majorité
à l'assemblée nationale a adopté le
projet de loi relatif à l'élection des
conseillers municipaux
les délégués communautaires des
conseillers départementaux dans une
version quand même très proche de celle
du projet initial du gouvernement
alors que le sait la ce le ministre vous
en souvenez avait rejeté en première
lecture le dit projet de loi faute
d'avoir pu dégager une majorité sur un
point essentiel à savoir la création du
binôme pour le nouveau conseiller
départemental en vue d'assurer à la fois
la parité absolue sans renoncer au
scrutin majoritaire cadrature du cercle
vous avez créé une forme bancal baroque
inconnue sur la planète et pourtant on
croyait avoir tout essayé en matière de
mode de scrutin
elle va vous vous pourrez ajouter
monsieur le ministre on connaissait le
système dont on a connu des gains et y
aura le système grâce nos concitoyens
n'y comprennent strictement rien
d'ailleurs
oui merci une manière oui je donne le
canton fera du droit électoral il y aura
le système valls donc alors en dehors du
fait en dehors du fait que l'on aboutit
vite à des contradictions par exemple
hausse du fait de la non possibilité de
réélection d'un membre du binôme en cas
de vacance définitive de l'un des sièges
comment dans ce cas réservé l'élection
un nouveau une femme est alors que vous
prétendez au maintien du caractère
proximité du conseiller général
alors que la représentation des
territoires ruraux auquel beaucoup
d'élus sont très attachés et si j'ai
bien compris surtout les bandes notre
assemblée
eh bien ils disparaître ou presque
complètement alors les les cantons sont
si vastes désormais deux élus qui
siégeront dans la solidarité ne durera
que le temps de l'élection
est-ce que messi mais si c'est ça faire
certes sur le ministre certes la config
vous verrez quand vous aurez à désigner
vos candidats on verra bon certes la
configuration démographique des
départements des pas homogène mais si
l'on s'en tient purement et même avec un
correctif de 20% au seul critère
démographique dans beaucoup de cas la
très grande majorité des élus
départementaux ne représentera plus que
les grandes villes où les métropoles le
secteur rural ou périurbain étant
abandonné 6 films permettent mais chers
collègues on a un exemple on a un
exemple on aboutira au même défaut pour
compte les conseils régionaux ou le
scrutin de liste favorise à l'évidence
et représentants des secteurs urbains
quand ce n'est pas ceux des appareils
politiques locaux d'ailleurs c'est assez
dire c'est assez dire qu'après avoir
entendu ce que nous avons entendu sur
les défauts du conseiller territorial et
monsieur le mini jeux vous a encore
entendu ce soir qu'ils étaient et
pourtant mes yeux une tentative
courageuse de simplifier
l'enchevêtrement des compétences et des
responsabilités des départements et des
régions
je les voter je l'assument beaucoup vous
l'avait combattu d'accord mais vous
allez voir dans quel guêpier où
allez-vous mettre beaucoup d'élus vont
s'apercevoir que la solution qui est
proposé n'est pas la bonne
et si elle était si merveilleuse
pourquoi ne pas l'appliquer aux députés
ça serait intéressant
alors là on inaugurait complètement
mais là je pense quand personne ne va se
livrer à ça alors il n'en demeure pas
moins monsieur le ministre que le
réalise puisque l'assemblée nationale a
voté cette disposition est le vôtre en
deuxième lecture nous contraint essayer
d'en limiter les défauts à savoir
principalement d'augmenter la marge
permettant une meilleure représentation
des territoires vous à vous l'avez dit
on peut nous objecter que le conseil
d'état a donné un avis sur cette
question d'ailleurs c'est normal comme
d'habitude on n'a jamais l'avis du
conseil d'état sauf quand on est dans
l'opposition vous le savez bien finit
toujours par le lavoir c'est comme ça et
se référant à la norme fixée par le
conseil constitutionnel pour découpage
des circonscriptions législatives
mais il nous semble que la comparaison
n'est pas impérieuse s'agissant des les
délires des gestionnaires locaux des
départements et qui doivent être certes
élu sur une base essentiellement
démographiques
sans négliger la représentation des
territoires et cette position qui a été
celle à deux reprises de la commission
des lois seraient valables même son
binôme puisque en tout état de cause la
carte cantonale deux doivent faire
l'objet devait faire l'objet d'une
refonte pour éviter les disparités qu'au
fil des décennies et même des siècles
les mutations des mégots démographie
concret si nous désapprouvons le report
des élections régionales qui n'ont à nos
yeux aucun motif d'intérêt général et
j'ai entendu dire ça serait tellement
bien de faire les cantonales en même
temps tu es régionales parce que ça
donnerait plus de puissance
est ce que ça vous pensez vraiment que
mélanger les deux ça éclaircit le débat
et les gens s'y retrouvent
on a déjà connu ça on a plus parlé du
tout des départements si c'est un des
buts qu'on poursuit on va finir par y
arriver alors
nous ne comprenons pas bien l'intérêt de
toute façon sauf a suscité de nombreuses
triangulaires de ramener le seuil pour
être présent au second tour à 10 % des
électeurs inscrits hélas comme pour le
cas précédent nous verrons quel accueil
sera réservé à nos amendements
la commission des lois ayant persisté au
premier comme au deuxième tour dans sa
volonté d'éviter ces triangulaire sur le
volet communal et comme le sénat l'avait
prévu en première lecture la diminution
du nombre de conseillers municipaux pour
les communes de moins de 100 habitants
mais c'est peut-être pas indispensable
en définitive pourrait paraître
pertinents c'est vrai que l'on connaît
des communes de 30 habitants pour
trouver neuf personnes c'est pas si
facile que ça et quelquefois il ya
quatre-vingts personnes mais il ya
cinquante électeurs et donc c'est quand
même pas si facile mais je procède
secondaire mais l'étendre à toutes les
communes de moins de 5
3500 habitants alors que il y a quelques
années linverse avait été opéré a
suscité beaucoup de réserves de la part
des élus locaux et la commission
d'ailleurs a dit ne changeons rien dans
ce domaine
concernant le seuil à partir duquel les
conseils municipaux seraient élus au
scrutin de liste
on peut comprendre les points de vue
différents et c'est vrai que les points
de vue exprimés ont été extrêmement
différents et même si nous souhaitions
nous souhaitons donc ce qu on déposera
un amendement fixé ce seuil à 1500
habitants il faut rappeler que
l'association des maires de france
s'étaient ralliés au seuil de 1000
habitants ce qui conforte d'ailleurs le
résultat de la consultation des élus
lors des états généraux de la démocratie
territoriale organisé par le sénat j'ai
le président vous conviendrez qu'il ne
faut pas balayer d'un revers de main
l'opinion des élus exprimé
majoritairement à cette occasion quand
même parce que si ça servira à rien les
états généraux il faut nous le dire
et comme je pense mais non mais
justement je pense que je serai soutenu
par le président du sénat sur ce point
voilà alors je vous rappelle d'ailleurs
que nous avons voté la loi organique en
première lecture
justement en raison de la fixation du
seuil à 1000 habitants reste enfin un
point important du débat
je sens poindre ne serait ce que par le
terme de conseillers communautaires un
mouvement récurrents disant
progressivement à effacer la commune au
profit de l'intercommunalité ou plutôt
d'une supra colline communalité prônée
par quelques experts qui ne se rendent
pas compte de la richesse de la
démocratie locale
grâce à ces trente six mille maire et à
ses cinq cent mille élus bénévoles les
mêmes les mêmes souhaite aussi
l'effacement du département mais nous
aurons à discuter de tout cela lors des
débats sur le projet décentralisation
qu'on nous promet et qui ne sera pas
triste me semble-t-il notre groupe
notre groupe j'ai oublié quoi
ben justement on avait on avait opté
pour le département en faisant de la
région une sorte d'interdît partement
l'été interdépartemental été veuillez
m'excuser si vous n'aviez pas compris ce
qu'on a essayé de faire c'est bien
dommage notre groupe soutient comme en
première lecture
l'article 20 dans la rédaction de la
commission des lois en laissant une
certaine souplesse à la désignation des
délégués des communes dans les
intercommunalités
c'est aussi un point très important
monsieur le ministre au seuil de ce
débat et comme nous sommes soucieux de
la responsabilité du sénat comme
représentants des collectivités locales
nous ne pouvons vous le savez bien
renoncer à notre position à ce qui fait
le coeur du projet
mais marquer des points de consensus
auquel nous pouvons parvenir
c'est la démarche de du groupe ump du
sénat
comment ne commencez pas à m'insulter
monsieur ne le jette autrement beaucoup
plus désagréable écoutez un peu les
autres lieux toujours hurler
si vous ne savez faire que ça c'est bien
dommage
pardon à l'est
nous ne sommes pas naïfs monsieur le
ministre nous
j'ai fait de l'argent ohlala nous ne
sommes pas naïfs au point de croire que
le gouvernement n'a aucune intention
électoraliste mais nous verrons bien
à l'issue de nos débats si la position
du sénat seront confortés sur certains
points ce qui règle serait de toute
façon un bénéfice pour la démocratie
locale
je vous remercie merci la parole est à
madame la présidente eliane assassi pour
le groupe crc
je suis
monsieur le président le ministre mes
chers collègues
c'est un peu mouillé sans rafraîchi je
sais pas si c'est nécessaire aux enduits
du train fléchi à brno lors de la
première lecture de ce texte monsieur le
ministre nous je commençais mon
intervention général de mémoire en
notant le peu de délai que nous avions
eu pour étudier le projet de le projet
de loi je rappelle que nous avions
commencé ces débats avant même que notre
commissionné étudier les amendements
déposés
je dois dire que pour la deuxième
lecture tout ceci ne s'est pas
franchement amélioré les amendements
commission devait être déposé avant même
que le texte ne soit adopté par
l'assemblée nationale avant même qu'ils
ne soient officiellement transmis à nos
trois haute assemblée et la commune
notre commission des lois a terminé
l'examen des amendements dits extérieurs
et vias simple simplement aller n'ont
peut-être pas quelques instants mais à
peine deux heures si le président du
groupe majoritaire a déclaré à la presse
il ya peu de temps qu'il serait temps
que les parlementaires soient respectés
par le gouvernement nous sommes là dans
des conditions d'examen d'un texte pour
le moins très limite au regard du droit
certes monsieur le ministre nous avons
bien compris que vous vouliez aller vite
mais vous voulez aller vite sans
vraiment prendre le temps d'écouter
celles et ceux qui à l'instar des élus
de mon groupe sont pourtant animé
s'agissant de ces textes d'un esprit
constructif je crois l'avoir dit
précisément au moment de la première
lecture je voudrais je voudrais rappeler
qu'au cours de nos débats je vous avais
dit notre accord sur un certain nombre
d'articles jeu et nous n'avons pas
changé d'avis
sur le point de désaccord je leur ai dit
nous avons fait des propositions
au final nous nous sommes abstenus sur
ce texte afin disions-nous de permettre
aux dialogues de se nouer dans le cas de
la navette mais force est de constater
qu'il n'en a rien été
alors comme nous sommes têtus nous
restons disponibles pour qu'un accord
puisse intervenir en particulier sur le
mode de scrutin des futurs conseillers
départementaux alors sur ce point nous
avons un petit échange vous connaissez
notre attachement de principe au scrutin
proportionnel qui est le seul permettant
une représentation démocratique
respectueuse des différents courants de
pensée qui traversent notre république
je rappelais donc il y à peine un mois
de cette tribune qu'il s'agissait même
d'un principe traditionnellement
soutenue par l'ensemble de la gauche
alors qu'elle est quelle a été notre
étonnement de vous entendre dire au
cours de nos débats ici que ce mode de
scrutin ne faisait pas partie de votre
de notre culture notre la gauche et
alors qu'il est en place dans deux
scrutins oui s'il te plaît david e alors
qu'il est en place dans deux scrutins
locaux sur trois et dans certains
départements pour l'élection des
sénateurs alors nous sommes heureux de
vous avoir entendu rappelé devant
l'assemblée nationale
l'attachement de la gauche à ce mode de
scrutin alors bon il faut vous suivre ça
c'est une évidence mais comme pour ma
part je regarde j'écoute mais surtout
j'entends j'ai entendu donc il ne reste
qu'à le mettre en place
dans une récente étude réalisée auprès
des délégués intercommunaux le soutien à
ce mode de scrutin est largement plus
important que celui en faveur de ce
binôme que vous continuez pourtant à
soutenir même nos débats de première
lecture ont montré que ce mode de
scrutin progresser dans l'opinion jusque
dans cet hémicycle
en effet de nombreux amendements de
gauche
comme de droite d'ailleurs proposé
différentes formes de mise en oeuvre de
la proportionnelle si nous faisions
alors le total des sénatrices et des
sénateurs proposant une forme de
proportionnelle il n'est pas sûr qu'ils
ne soient majoritaires au sénat
certes les différents modes proposés
divers sur de nombreux points mais il
nous sommes que les parlementaires et
les citoyens sont prêts à prendre en
compte ce mode de représentation
il était alors courageux d'affronter les
interrogations légitimes et les opinions
contraires en proposant pour les
conseillers départementaux un nouveau
mode de scrutin
respectant le pluralisme et la parité
le binôme républicains indissociables
auquel nous sommes très attachés à ce
propos qu'il me soit permis ici de
relever un argument souvent utilisée
contre ce mode de scrutin à propos du 10
ans du soi disant manque de lien avec
les territoires et les citoyens lors
d'un scrutin proportionnel
si dans une commune lors des élections
municipales chaque liste fait son
possible pour que chaque quartier chaque
territoire qui la composent soient
représentées parmi ces candidats au
niveau départemental chacun sait bien
qu'une liste de candidats aura
l'impérieuse nécessité de faire de même
si elle souhaite réunir sur son nom un
nombre conséquent des lecteurs et je
pense que l'on peut faire confiance au
débat électoral pour mettre à l'index tu
les listes qui n'agirait pas ainsi enfin
si des élus n'arrivait pas à enraciner
leurs actions dans un territoire leur
réélection serait difficile aussi la
représentation des territoires est nous
semble-t-il possible avec la
proportionnelle qui plus est je rappelle
que nous avons fait une proposition de
repli qui permettrait de maintenir un
rattachement locale en effet en
instaurant une proportionnelle
correctives elle permettrait d'attribuer
des sièges à des sensibilités y n'ayant
pas obtenu dans les cantons l'heure
juste représentation et de rééquilibrer
les écarts en termes de parité
finalement pour instaurer la
proportionnelle ou en introduire une
dose il aurait fallu que le gogo il
aurait fallu que le gouvernement le
souhaite et à l'évidence ce n'est pas sa
volonté
vous avez préféré monsieur le ministre
vous donner l'objectif de renforcer le
bipartisme dans la vie politique
nous le regrettons d'autant que chacun
sait que s'il est vrai que la
proposition de binômes assurera la
parité ça c'est indéniable et vous savez
là aussi combien mon groupe est attaché
à l'aparté il n'en demeure pas moins que
cette proposition fera reculer le
pluralisme
tout en ne permettant pas une réelle
représentation des territoires
en effet avec le double mouvement de la
réforme nécessaire du périmètre des
cantons que nous soutenons et de votre
projet de binômes regroupant deux
cantons en un ceux ci seront dorénavant
d'une telle taille que l'on ne pourra
plus parler de proximité ni de lien
véritable avec des territoires de vie
identifiés et reconnus
cela sera particulièrement ressenti dans
les territoires ruraux
peu à peu les deux conseillers
territoriaux d'un même canton
s'éloigneront de leurs électeurs dans
une immense circonscription électorale
regroupant parfois plusieurs dizaines de
communes aussi une nouvelle fois nous
vous demandons monsieur le ministre si
vous voulez bien m'écouter de revoir
votre proposition qui ferait du scrutin
départemental un anachronisme
démocratique dans notre pays
toutes les autres élections locales
permettent une répartition
proportionnelle des sièges au sein de
leur assemblée l'élection des sénateurs
se fait dans certains départements à la
proportionnelle et il me semble que vous
soutiendrez prochainement un projet de
loi pour élargir encore ce mode de
scrutin sénatorial
enfin suite à la commission jose pas
vous
allez présenter devant nous un texte
introduisant une part de
proportionnalité monsieur patriat je ne
savais pas que les mi6 avait aussi
d'audition des parlementaires avec les
ministres et leurs cabinets s'il vous
plaît je ne suis pas sûr que si je
faisais la même chose qui ne m'arrivera
jamais vous ne m'en voudrez pas donc si
la commission suite à la commission je
sais pas vous allez présenter devant
nous un texte introduisant une part de
proportionnelle pour l'élection des
députés danseurs dans ce contexte c'est
ce qui était ce qui a été dit en tout
cas ce que nous avons lu et entendu dans
ce contexte dans ce mouvement
pourrions-nous dire que vous allez
initié en faveur de la proportionnelle
votre excusez moi du propos rigidités
sur cette question pour le scrutin
départemental
tout ça me semble un peu inexplicable il
vous faudra cependant vous en expliquer
devant les élus locaux les électeurs
nous ne sommes pas sûrs qu'ils soient
prêts à entendre des arguments
finalement contradictoires l'autre point
de désaccord que nous avons concernées
et vous savez aussi le nouveau mode
d'élection des délégués communautaires
là aussi mettant en oeuvre les
préconisations de la commission balladur
contenant contenu dans la loi de nicolas
sarkozy 2010 tu votre proposition
installe une rupture qu'il ne fera que
s'élargir entre les communes et les
intercommunalités
certes ne seront plus ce ne seront plus
pardon les conseils municipaux qui
seront représentés au sein des
assemblées délibérantes des
intercommunalités mais des conseillers
élus au suffrage universel appelé à
gérer ces structures en toute
indépendance sans tenir compte des élus
communaux devant lesquels ils n'auront
plus de comptes à rendre
ce mode de scrutin est présenté comme
une avancée démocratique car elle donne
la parole à paroles directement au
peuple
en fait c'est un détournement
démocratique car ce scrutin vise à faire
disparaître la commune qui est la
structure démocratique de base de notre
république
par ailleurs elle met à mal à terme nos
départements par la place toujours plus
grande que les intercommunalités sont
appelés à prendre
en élargissant leur territoire et leur
compétence dans l'expression même de
notre réalité politique locale nous
sommes passés de la commune au bloc
communal demain ce glissement sémantique
deviendra le bloc local intégrant nos
départements d'ailleurs c'est déjà le
cas avec les métropoles façon 2010 et
cela le sera encore plus avec la future
je sais pas quand lois de
décentralisation que le gouvernement
prépare pour on ne sait pas quand de
plus vous l'avez reconnu devant nous est
rappelé à l'assemblée nationale ce mode
de scrutin n'est qu'une étape vers une
élection totalement indépendante
vous en fixe et même le terme à 2020 ce
faisant chacun le sait il s'agit aussi
du terme que vous fixée pour
l'extinction des communes telles que
nous les connaissons aujourd'hui leur
avenir sera de devenir un cadre
administratif de base un secteur d'une
entité bien plus large
d'ailleurs il faut vous reconnaitre
quand même pour le coup la clarté de vos
propositions et là encore votre votre
honnêteté dans le projet de
décentralisation
vous ne parlez plus de coopération pour
qualifier la relation entre les communes
et les intercommunalités mais bel et
bien d'intégration ainsi au lieu de nos
3000 6e 36 communes aux pouvoirs étendus
nous aurons deux mille cinq cents
collectivités territoriales de
remplacement les ayant finalement
totalement intégré certains
parlementaires de votre majorité sont
même pour accélérer ce mouvement nous
aurons un débat un amendement de nos
collègues écologistes allant dans ce
sens nous nous souvenons même que
d'autres présidents chauffeur défendez
un amendement de même type au cours
de nos débats sur la réforme de 2010
c'est dire
le désaccord que nous avons entre nous
au sein de la gauche
là aussi c'est un constat mais sur ce
point vous êtes assurés d'avoir un vote
très largement majoritaires dans notre
assemblée puisque les sénateurs
centristes et les sénateurs de droite
sont favorables à cette mesure qui
prolonge la loi de 2010 on ne peut pas
leur reprocher une certaine cohérence
nous continuerons mesdames et messieurs
les élus de l'opposition a demandé
l'abrogation de la loi de monsieur
sarkozy de 2007
nous sommes bien les seuls à l'évidence
dans cet hémicycle à défendre une telle
proposition mais nous savons que cet
avis est partagé par un très grand
nombre d'élus locaux c'est chacun se
souvient souvent sur cette base que le
basculement à gauche de notre sénat
s'est produit d'ailleurs cela a été
confirmé et rappelé tout à l'heure par
les états généraux de la démocratie
territoriale que notre assemblée a
organisé et n'oublions pas le résultat
du questionnaire auquel 20000 et lui
aurait pondu sur cette question du
fléchage hills était une large majorité
à demander que l'élection des délégués
communautaires continuent à se faire
dans chaque conseil municipal
aussi si nous avons soutenu cette
initiative
c'était non seulement pour écouter les
élus mais surtout pour qu'il soit
entendu
or sur cette question une autre sénat
s'apprête à rester sourd à leurs
demandes
pas nous enfin je termine mon
intervention réaffirmant notre
attachement comme le demandait aussi les
élus locaux dans ce questionnaire à
l'abaissement du seuil installant le
mode de scrutin de liste aux élections
municipales
si nous sommes favorables à ce type
d'élection dans toutes les communes
nous sommes prêts à soutenir toutes les
avancées qui augmenterait le nombre de
communes qui seraient assujettis en
première lecture nous nous souvenons que
le seuil de 500 habitants que nous
proposions a failli être adoptées
l'assemblée nationale a retenu cette
proposition mais notre commission a
décidé de revenir à mille
alors que de très nombreuses voix
s'élèvent en faveur d'un abaissement de
ce seuil significatif pourquoi pourquoi
cette frilosité de la chambre
représentant les collectivités locales
pourquoi n'ont-elles pas cet appel à la
fin du tir au pigeon qu'est devenu le
mode d'élection dans les plus petites
communes qui ne fait que découragé bon
nombre de l'ue est raréfié les candidats
potentiels aux fonctions électives
locales
donc nous espérons que dans sa grande
sagesse notre sénat rétablira le texte
adopté par l'assemblée nationale donc
c'est vraiment sur cette note
d'optimiste que je terminerai mon propos
nous apprêtons quand même à ne pas
soutenir votre texte monsieur le
ministre
sauf coup de théâtre nos désaccords est
en profond sur deux points essentiels de
ce projet et sincèrement
compte tenu que notre abstention comment
dire d'ouverture au dialogue en première
lecture et je crois me rappeler que j'ai
non seulement ouvert les portes mais
j'ai offert aussi les fenêtres et la
porte de la cave
mais visiblement cela n'a pas été suivi
d'effet
donc ce faisant nous ne pourrons que
voté contre ce projet de loi
si la parole est à monsieur jean léonce
dupont du groupe u10 uc
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues un
hebdomadaire de cette semaine titre un
bref article
les hollandais ne pense qu'à ça les
soutiens de françois hollande prépare
déjà son second mandat
quelques 300 personnes dont une dizaine
de ministres se sont réunis à
l'assemblée nationale dans ce but et un
député socialiste d'expliquer je le cite
l'objectif est clair c'est la réélection
de françois hollande en 2017
lors de la première lecture du projet de
loi relatif à l'élection des conseillers
départementaux des conseillers
municipaux et des délégués
communautaires et modifiant le
calendrier électoral
bon nombre de parlementaires ont dénoncé
un texte élaboré à partir de calcul
politicien visant à limiter d'éventuels
déroute électorale lors des prochaines
élections locales mais qui sera
destructeur pour l' équilibre entre les
territoires urbains et des territoires
ruraux alone à l'aune de l'objectif
aussi nettement affichée à peine neuf
mois après l'élection en question
permettez-moi de renouveler ses
interrogations et inquiétudes quant à la
conception de l'intérêt général du
gouvernement qui fait croire aux élus à
une grande consultation concertation sur
une réforme territoriale mais présente
au parlement des projets de loi
répondant aux intérêts d'un seul parti
sur le fond du texte examiné aujourd'hui
je comprends la nécessité de tenir
compte des évolutions démographiques et
donc de réduire l'écart de population
entre les cantons car la carte communale
certains départements ce n'est pas le
cas du calvados n'a pas été revu depuis
fort longtemps
je reconnais aussi que le changement de
dénomination d'institutions et des élus
respectivement conseil départemental et
conseiller départemental seront plus
explicite pour nos concitoyens
j'approuve également
le principe de renouvellement complet du
futur conseil départemental tous les six
ans mais je suis particulièrement
inquiet des conséquences du redécoupage
de la carte électorale telle
qu'envisagée par le gouvernement et du
mode de scrutin retenu
l'article 2 du projet de loi prévoit un
nouveau mode de scrutin aux élections
cantonales bientôt départementale les
candidats se présenteront en binôme un
homme une femme au scrutin majoritaire à
deux tours
dans un canton redécouper une femme un
homme bien entendu je dois admettre que
le mode de scrutin proposé et créatif
mais d'une créativité
je dirais similaire à celle à l'origine
des 35 heures celle que personne ne nous
envie celle que personne ne copie même
notre rapporteur souligné dans son
rapport de la première de première
lecture que ce nouveau mode de scrutin
binominal ne dispose d'aucun équivalent
dont les scrutins électoraux applicable
dans d'autres pays
mes inquiétudes quant à cette réforme ne
porte pas sur l'affichage d'une nouvelle
exception française
mais aux conséquences du système
envisagé sous couvert d'améliorer la
parité des élus départementaux un binôme
mix solidaire pendant la campagne
électorale puis indépendants une fois
élu a été imaginé j'ai les plus vives
interrogations canton fonctionnement a
longtemps efficace dans la durée pour le
canton et sa population de ce fameux
couple imposée je formule plutôt des
craintes quant au développement d'une
compétition entre eux plus graves seront
les ruptures et fracture entre
territoires jusqu'à présent jusqu'à
présent un fragile équilibre existe
entre la représentation de la population
avec les élections législatives et
régionales et la représentation des
territoires avec les cantonales et les
sénatoriales
si demain on applique le nouveau mode de
scrutin avec le redécoupage annoncée de
la carte cantonale
c'est inévitablement un basculement
qui va s'opérer avec un affaiblissement
important de la représentation des
territoires ruraux et un travail du
futur conseiller départemental entre
celui qui représentera un quartier de
ville et celui qui représentera entre 60
et 100 communes rurales
rien que le repas des anciens rien que
le repas des anciens jouent donne
beaucoup de courage ainsi dans le
calvados pour atteindre uniformément la
moyenne départementale requise
les cantons redécoupés devront réunir
trois ou quatre cantons ruraux actuelle
c'est le rôle de fer équation du conseil
général dans l'aménagement du territoire
qui sera mise à mal vous le savez tous
le conseil général est le premier
partenaire des communes et des
communautés de communes
il est également présent dans chaque
canton auprès des tpe et du monde
agricole
nos territoires ne constitue pas
seulement un nombre équivalent
d'individus et de famille
ce sont des espaces de vie avec leurs
histoires leurs géraud d'affi leurs
spécificités leurs activités
différencier qu'elle soit économique ou
liées à la préservation de la ruralité
et de l'environnement elle constitue
également un maillage de villes et de
villages où les problèmes et les projets
développement ne peuvent se réduire à
une simple approche arithmétique
c'est pourquoi afin de maintenir une
représentation optimale des territoires
sans retenir comme unique critère une
approche arithmétique
je suis partisan comme au collègue hervé
maurey dont j'ai cosigné les amendements
ce sens d'un mode de scrutin mixte
combinant le recours au scrutin
majoritaire dans les zones rurales et
l'instauration d'un scrutin
proportionnel à un tour avec prime
majoritaire dans les zones urbaines
un tel dispositif
combiné avec un redécoupage des cantons
qui respecterait autant que possible les
périmètres des intercommunalités afin
d'assurer une cohérence territoriale
garantirait le respect des territoires
ruraux et la juste représentation des
territoires urbains
en outre il assurerait la nécessité
émergence de majorité stable au sein des
assemblées départementales et le respect
de la parité à défaut de retenir un tel
mode de scrutin mixte
je dois reconnaître deux avancées
significatives du volley départemental
du texte tel qu'adopté par les députés
qui traduisent une évolution dans la
prise de conscience la prise en compte
de la cohérence territoriale
premièrement le nouvel article 1 bis
votée à l'initiative du groupe u10
l'assemblée nationale qui précise dans
le code général des collectivités
territoriales que le conseil général
représentent la population et les
territoires qui la composent est ainsi
réaffirmé le rôle du département comme
garant de la solidarité sociale et de la
solidarité territoriale et j'en conclus
que tout projet de redécoupage devra
prendre en compte non seulement la
démographie mais également la
représentation des territoires du
département
je me réjouis que la commission des lois
propose d'adopter cette disposition sans
modification deuxièmement à l'article 23
relatifs aux principes encadrant la
procédure de remodelage de la carte
cantonale
les députés ont élargi les dérogations
possibles afin qu'ils puissent être tenu
compte des considérations géographiques
de répartition de la population sur le
territoire d'aménagement du territoire
ou pour d'autres impératif d'intérêt
général
j'espère que le sénat poursuivra en ce
sens prenant mieux en compte les zones à
faible densité de population mais
également à cohérence territoriale
l'ancrage territorial des élus au sein
leur circonscription
à l'origine d'un lien de proximité entre
ces derniers et leurs électeurs sont
ainsi moins mises à mal que dans le
projet de loi initial
au final je demeure vous l'avez compris
opposé à ce texte lourd de conséquences
pour les territoires et je désapprouve
les calculs politiciens qui sous tendent
actuellement les textes modifiant le
droit électoral redécoupage de la carte
électorale
modification du mode de scrutin cantonal
à un an des élections
modification du calendrier électoral
abaissement du seuil de maintien au
second tour
des binômes multipliant ainsi les
risques de triangulaire modifications à
venir du mode de scrutin sénatorial
tout cela sont autant d'éléments qui me
font craindre que les seules motivations
du gouvernement sont électoraliste et
non liée à l'intérêt général et au
meilleur fonctionnement de notre
démocratie
merci la parole est à présent à monsieur
le président jacques mézard pour le
groupe rdse
je peux monter le ton
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le texte
relatif à l'élection des conseillers
départementaux municipaux et des
délégués communautaires nous revient de
l'assemblée nationale un peu comme une
rose dont la tige est plus chargé des
pin que le texte initial du gouvernement
ce n'est point une surprise à
l'activisme des députés s'est ajoutée et
cela nous concerne le fait que le sénat
en ne votant pas l'article 2 nous nous
lavions voter avait pris le risque
d'écarter un débat qui avait tout son
sens dans la haute assemblée à laquelle
faut-il le rappeler l'article 24 de la
constitution donne mission de
représenter encore pour l'instant les
collectivités territoriales on ne peut
reprocher au ministre de l'intérieur
d'avoir initié un projet de loi relatif
aux élections départementales et
municipales
c'était une obligation découlant
premièrement de ce que le conseiller
territorial avait été créée par la loi
et que la nouvelle majorité s'étaient
engagées à le supprimer
d'ailleurs avec le soulagement implicite
de nombre d'élus de l'ancienne majorité
et deuxièmement et deuxièmement parce
que le conseil d'état et le conseil
constitutionnel indiqué fermement que
les déséquilibres démographiques entre
cantons devait être impérativement
modifié l'enterrement du conseiller
territorial fut célébrée dans la joie la
naissance du conseiller départemental
les ai vécues dans l'inquiétude et
l'incompréhension due à l'arrivée
inopinée de deux faux jumeaux de sexe
opposé
il fallait donc imaginer et construire
un nouveau dispositif en respectant des
équilibres démographiques tout en tenant
compte de la réalité et de la diversité
des territoires et en intégrant
l'objectif de parité
très simplement cela ressemble un peu à
la quadrature du cercle
la solution la plus simple celle qui
aurait généré le moindre remous les qui
aurait eu notre préférence utt en
conservant le système électoral actuel
de remodeler les cantons pour remédier
aux déséquilibres démographiques
j'entends votre objection cela ne
solutionnerait pas la question de la
parité laquelle n'évoluerait que
lentement malgré la mise en place des
remplaçants des conseillers généraux
c'est une objection recevable même si la
recherche mathématique et systématique
de la parité abouti parfois des
solutions peu raisonnable on vient de
vivre la séquence du binôme dans la
présidence des groupes parlementaires
avec l'issue que l'on connaît à quand le
binôme à la présidence de la république
la solution la solution de l'élection
départementale à la proportionnelle
avait été envisagé vous l'avez écartée
monsieur le ministre et nous vous en
remercions
car si la proportionnelle permet de
résoudre positivement la question de la
parité
elle présente des défauts considérable à
nos yeux
le premier est temps de couper le lien
entre l'élu et le territoire ce qui est
pour nous un élément essentiel de la vie
démocratique
le système est évidemment désirer
ardemment par les militants et
professionnels de la politique
les futurs élus étant choisis dans les
sections des partis dans des conditions
que l'on connaît trop de fêtes
de fait avec un tel système laisser les
électeurs choisir est la tête de liste
futur président du conseil départemental
et non les suivants de liste vous en
avez un exemple pratique avec les
conseils régionaux les électeurs
connaissent et choisissent le président
du conseil régional
mais dans les départements ils ignorent
totalement le nom et même l'existence
des conseillers régionaux les exécutifs
fonctionne avec une majorité stable
c'est vrai mais est ce une bonne
illustration de la représentation
démographique
je n'en rajouterai pas une couche avec
les circonscriptions des députés
européens caricature s'il en est de
l'expression démocratique et de la
confiscation du pouvoir par des
apparatchiks de quelques parties que
l'on ne revoit jamais dans les
circonscriptions après l'élection
monsieur le ministre la proportionnelle
aurait pu être retenu uniquement dans
les zones très urbaine il y à bien pour
l'élection sénatoriale de mode de
scrutin différent à étiage flottants
selon le pouvoir en place
vous auriez conserver le scrutin actuel
hors zone urbaine en fait cela avait un
inconvénient politique pour le parti
majoritaire
c'est vrai en général on préfère
partager le bien des autres que le sien
après avoir éliminé le système actuel et
la proportionnelle départementale il
fallait trouver un autre système
le binôme s'est imposée soudainement
présenté comme le moins mauvais des
systèmes sans d'ailleurs que l'on
identifie le vrai père ou la vraie mère
dudit système
c'est un peu comme le conseiller
territorial cela soulève tellement d'
enthousiasme qu aucun doigt ne se lèvent
pour revendiquer l'idée géniale
ce qui est regrettable c'est d'avoir
considéré sans une véritable
concertation préalable j'entends par
conservation non un aimable entretien
d'information mais de réunions de
travail que c'était le seul système
possible
notre collègue pierre yves collombat a
démontré par ses propositions sur un
scrutin proportionnel caler sur les
intercommunalités que l'on pouvait
conjuguer représentation
du territoire et parité cela en tout cas
méritait d'être étudié le binôme va
passer en force à l'assemblée nationale
des voix de députés grandes et petites
l'ont proclamé dans un garde-à-vous
impressionnant signature de la vème
république
de ce côté là vous avez fait fort
pendant longtemps le système du binôme
n'existe dans aucun autre pays du monde
la france innove donne l'exemple et à ce
moment je ne résiste pas au plaisir de
vous rappeler cette phrase de jean
françois revel depuis que la france
rayonne je me demande comment le monde
entier n'est pas mort d'insolation mais
puisque le binôme va illuminer notre
démocratie monsieur le ministre
ne soyez pas sourd au message qui
remonte de nos territoires aux petites
voix de nos petits territoires trop
méconnu dans les visions de l'île de
france sur le principe nous ne sommes
toujours pas convaincus de la
constitutionnalité du scrutin binominal
de la soustraction au principe de
l'individualisation de l'égalité de
représentation
peut-on concevoir une individualisation
binominal nous ne sommes toujours pas
convaincu du choix de la procédure
réglementaire sur le découpage des
cantons
car il nous semble que s'agissant d'une
modification général de circonscription
électorale cela relèverait plutôt de la
procédure législative surtout un
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
le projet de loi est ressentie dans nos
départements qualifié de ruraux comme un
facteur supplémentaire de déséquilibre
territorial de fracture territoriale à
l'intérieur même de nos départements
quand vous rajoutez couche après couche
les questions de péréquation
départementale lamentablement dévoyé par
le vote du 16 décembre à l'assemblée
nationale de carte scolaire d'avenir ou
non des sous-préfectures de retrait des
services de l'état aggravée par une rgpp
aveugle chers collègues de l'opposition
vous devez comprendre monsieur le
ministre que la création dimanche
ton ruraux regroupant un nombre
considérable de communes avec la
disparition de nombreux chefs lieux de
canton évidemment à paris est chef lieu
de canton c'est parce que c'est ce qui
entraînera des conséquences malgré les
propos rassurants du rapport cela
inquiète cela angoisse nombre d'élus
locaux pas seulement ceux qui vont être
euthanasié par cette loi et aussi de nos
concitoyens la france rurale avait peur
du conseiller territorial elle exprima
par le vote sénatoriales de 2011
elle est inquiète aujourd'hui du binôme
elle exprimera demain parce que cette
france à constater l'abandon depuis
plusieurs années d'une véritable
politique d'aménagement du territoire
la concentration du développement
économique autour des métropoles
nationales et régionales
l'ajout de la fracture numérique aux
autres handicaps dont les déserts de
santé ne croyez pas monsieur le ministre
que je m'éloigne du débat j'y suis au
coeur et ne nous cachons pas derrière
des paravents
oui ce à quoi ce gouvernement comme le
gouvernement précédent se refuse c'est
dire clairement quel avenir au moins à
moyen terme vous entendez réservé au
département s l'évaporation
balladurienne est ce une recomposition
toute vision toute prospective sont
souhaitables sont respectables
à condition de les exprimer certes le
président de la république a dit faire
confiance au sénat pour réécrire le
projet de loi de madame lebranchu
les ministres concernés ont dû apprécier
mais voulez vous faire confiance au
sénat pour réécrire le projet binôme et
demain le projet non cumul nous sommes à
votre disposition
dans cette optique et dans un objectif
constructif il faut monsieur le ministre
que vous entendiez qu'il n'est pas
raisonnable de se cramponner à la règle
des moins 20 + 1 pour la création des
nouveaux cantons
que le système de dérogations
particulières en fonction des zones de
montagne ou littorales ou autre serait
pour nos purement arbitraire injuste
générateur de multiples contentieux
oui comme nous l'avons proposé en
première lecture et comme cela était
justement accepté par la commission des
lois fallait revenir au système venir au
système -30 +30 qui seul évitera la
création de canton gigantesque sans
aucune cohérence ne permettant plus une
représentation efficace et juste des
populations concernées
oui un conseiller départemental doit
avoir une vision globale de l'action à
mener dans son département
mais cette action globale elle ne peut
ni ne doit abandonner les cantons les
moins peuplées où les handicaps
géographiques sont les plus lourds un
canton au sein d'une grande ville n'a
rien à voir avec un canton en zone de
montagne
c'est toute la difficulté de l'exercice
il est des territoires où la suppression
d'un canton sur deux aura des
conséquences dommageables et je déplore
une nouvelle fois que l'utilisation
stricte de l'article 40 et balayer nos
amendements relatifs au nombre de
cantons un mot sur le seuil du scrutin
pour accéder au second tour
nous avons toujours défendu un seuil
assez bas pour préserver l'expression
des partis minoritaires
nous comprenons néanmoins l'attachement
de l'ump au seuil de 2 et demi pour cent
pour éviter la représentation des
extrêmes populiste mais nous refusons le
système votée par la commission
réservant deuxième tour aux deux
premiers il y en a déjà assez avec
l'élection présidentielle ne
bipolarisation bipolariser pas à
outrance la vie politique locale
je n'en doutais pas à monsieur le
président en sueur ce qui prouve
l'évolution de la commission au fil des
heures
quant à l'élection des conseillers
municipaux et communautaires
nous avons approuvé l'essentiel des
dispositions que vous proposez sous
réserve de certains amendements
nous avons beaucoup lutté pour que le
seuil d'application du scrutin de liste
reste comme vous l'aviez proposer
monsieur le ministre
dans le projet à 1000 habitants
descendre à 500 auraient des
inconvénients majeurs surtout dans la
constitution de plusieurs listes en
corollaire le sénat avait voté à
l'unanimité
mon amendement diminuant le nombre de
conseillers municipaux uniquement au
dessous du seuil de 100 habitants
car quel intérêt de diminuer le nombre
des conseillers municipaux
ils sont bénévoles attachés à leur
commune et constitue un élément de lien
social
irremplaçable en outre la représentation
dans les intercommunalités par les
maires des petites communes qui seront
seules surchargés de travail justifie de
ne pas diminuer le nombre de conseillers
municipaux
enfin en ce qui concerne l'élection des
délégués communautaires favorable au
fléchage nous souhaitons la plus grande
liberté est la plus grande simplicité
dans le dispositif
vous le savez monsieur le ministre ce
texte suscite parmi les sénateurs de
bons groupes du rds eu bien des
interrogations
parce que viscéralement a convaincu de
la nécessité du lien direct entre l'élu
et le territoire de la nécessité de la
représentation non seulement des
citoyens mais des territoires il et les
orientations qui nous inquiètent
notre groupe exprimera vraisemblablement
des votes divers en fonction des
sensibilités diverses qui est qui s'y
expriment librement sur le ministre vous
exprimer une conception de la république
que nous partageons sur bien des points
je comprends que le vote du sénat ne
vous satisfasse pas mais n'écartez pas
ce qu'ils expriment non contre vous dont
nous apprécions au jour le jour l'action
le travail mais pour une conception de
notre république et de son organisation
que les réformes ne doivent pas
fragiliser les conforter
merci la parole est à madame hélène les
pièces pour le groupe écologiste
je vous
monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous nous apprêtons à vivre un nouveau
marathon aux sénatoriales pour la
seconde lecture de ce projet de loi
concernant les élections départementales
et la désignation des conseillers
communautaires
ma plus grande espérance parler d'espoir
serait trop terre-à-terre et que notre
nouveau débat soit plus à la hauteur que
le précédent plus respectueux de nos
futurs collègues qui ce qu'ils feront
leur entrée dans nos assemblées
départementales elles ne sont pas des
gadgets ni une prime pour le repos de
l'élu elles n'auront pas à faire leurs
preuves et les administrations auront
toujours le pouvoir que nous élus leur
laisseront notamment par notre
absentéisme elles seront des politiques
car elles le sont déjà
elles seront aussi responsable que les
hommes du bien-être de la société
après avoir été pendant des siècles les
faits du foyer elles auront les défauts
des hommes leur incompétence mais aussi
leur qualité et leur pugnacité comme
vous et moi
bref j'espère que la honte de nos
précédents débats puissent passer aux
oubliettes de la toute petite histoire
reste le regret de n'avoir su faire que
le texte présenté à l'assemblée soit
notre texte le sexe le texte du sénat en
lieu et place du texte du gouvernement
certes nous autres écologistes avons
contribué à son rejet par notre haute
assemblée nous en sommes conscients
mais pas plus pas moins que les autres
groupes à vous avons-nous su nous
entendre sur la rénovation de nos
institutions
avons-nous su trouver le plus petit
dénominateur commun possible pour nous
retrouver
alors que nous sommes si opposées entre
les partisans du conseiller territorial
les adversaires du scrutin binominal les
partisans du tout proportionnelle et ce
dock une proportionnalité ceux d'une
intercours communalité des communes
et ceux pour lesquels l'internaute
communalité fait peur et un gouvernement
incapable d'entendre même les
propositions de forme que je lui
proposais parce que venant d'une
écologiste la précédente discussion n'a
pu n'a su trouver le chemin du compromis
puisse cette nouvelle discussion
permettre enfin une véritable écoute de
tous les avis elle a d'ailleurs déjà
bien commencé dès l'étude en commission
des lois
ainsi nous avons acté le renversement du
privilège de l'âge que l'assemblée
n'avait pas repris
j'en fus étonné je pensais que
l'assemblée nationale plus nombreuses
plus jeune et dynamique aurez bien
compris notre démarche
je pensais la loi
la politique n'est pas faite la loi la
politique n'est pas faite pour le passé
elle est faite pour l'avenir il faut
savoir passer la main en accompagnant
les plus jeunes et non pas en se
cantonnant à au bras de son fauteuil
aussi un coût aussi confortable soit il
ce n'est donc pas une affaire de
jeunesse